my name is mike miller I'm I'm just
placing for about 15 years now
and I'm with spice in academia action in
the founder of passing Academy and we
teach Python or kinds of Python from
very beginning to advanced course of
scientists courses and web development
it's about like be about six trainers
now in total and we really focus on
Python and we can read offer very
advanced and are specialized Python
courses that's what we do and I was
teach a lot of tutorials so I go to Pike
on us in April and will teach the tour
of 14 and 15 there so I'm do a lot of
those things and this is just a small
part of but you can do is Python some
examples that fits in this high
performance track here and this talk
very nicely fits together with but just
Ian Ian just Gator gable overview of
this high-performance landscape in pizen
by profiling and some tools and I would
like to focus on one tool and especially
on the parallel aspect so everybody
knows things getting parallel things are
parallel already and it will be way more
parallelism in the future and this GPU
seems like the GPU kind of merge with
normal cpu more or less in one way or
the other though giving you even more
course so probably soon we will talk
about hundreds and thousands of course
when you want to go parallel and there
are different approaches people rock
with it it's not simple they are still
things things involved there but there
are some some tools there and they will
get get get better we saw there's a lot
of development a lot of new things and i
will show you one thing so the first
thing i want to introduce you to size on
so science and we saw already at such as
when you go in bit more detail is a
mixture between python and scenes a very
nice mixture so if you have normal
python is just compiler to size and the
different knots English change the
single line and you get the extension
module it won't get much faster but you
can do it so Stefan bendel he's a one of
the core developers my fluorescence also
heroes the Rockland choice on his
somewhere here at least of the
conference I'll talk to him your last
night and today in yesterday and he
compiled the whole standard library in
Python I think 600 module is compiled on
the two didn't compile so you can
compile everything too
share two shared libraries so you then
you have some people say oh did we do
not distribute pison bytecode p1 just
give shared libraries then you can do
this and we might get a bit faster and
they talk to other people just have
normal projects and they got about forty
percent faster just by compiling every
single size and don't change a single
thing that's one way of doing it but the
nice thing is you can gradually go from
Python to see and get and see where the
weather time goes so we look at this
annotation and also size not only
supports seed or supports c++ which is
important so you can rep see press pass
it's a bit the work because we have to
put some manual work in there but you
can give your interface nice pythonic
flavor if you want to so like see
exceptions will be turned into C++
exceptions will be turned into pies and
exceptions and then if you have a bunch
of kettles and settles and stuff you can
change into properties and things like
this so you can make nice interfaces and
this is something you might be able to
automate some way or the other but very
often for every library it's been
different so I owe you do it by hand i
write your own tools that it's always an
opportunity sometimes writing on tools
is better than trying to shoehorn a to
Alexis and some some way so it's always
a advantages disadvantages and the whole
thing um compiled to shared library soo
PYD which is a pison dll windows and it
works pretty pretty well makes things
much easier if i ever written the
extension by hand which had things very
few people still do so i remember back
ten years or even longer then you wrote
those things by hand which is a little
work so there's a lot of users of size
and so even though you don't use size on
yourself you do because a lot of a lot
of tools you syfy use the signs and
pandas makes a lot of your size and
height table 0 and Q SH and out quite a
few others they all use size and in the
background to wrap see so obviously it
works there and they get something out
of it so your extension will be as fast
as as you write things yourself but as
much much less work much more convenient
to brokers so how does it work the sign
says workflow you actually you create ap
bio x5 we see there are other
possibilities but that's usually how you
do it you create the pyx file and px
can be just pure python file in the
beginning we will do this and then you
can add some additional information that
gives the size and compiler information
what do what do i do you want but you
mean so type annotations mainly that's
something you can do and then you
actually compile the thing this will set
up five we look at it in for an example
and you get this extension module and
you can use extensions so you can ship
extension so the means you work with
ricin your user doesn't need science & u
compila you just rip your extension and
they don't need a bottle sighs and don't
need a compiler on Windows very often if
you have normal users they don't have AC
compiler installed and nobody'd once
potable compile an thing so you can ship
extensions and this works that's one way
of doing it let's look an example so i
had just i try to boil down the code to
very simple example otherwise we get
quite more involved in the end but to
understand the principle so they have
your pure pison function which is just
the add function so we have a and B here
a and B when you just added and you'll
get the result and then you can do
something is called the CDF and the CDF
is a function that is a real c function
so there's a lot of additional quite a
few additional keyboards there and one
of them is c def in and size on so this
function would run a normal Python no
problem this would be just a number
Python function and this would would not
run you cannot use it from Python it's
only available from see you have to
write a wrap around it so that's what
i'm doing here and you see the first
thing I just said the whole thing is is
a returns a double here because I say I
want to have a double this is new and
then I say a and B are doubles this and
this means really see doubles whatever
she understands there will be a
translated and then you can do to use it
you have to write a final function here
that actually is calling this function
to make it work to make it koala balloon
Python to do this that's all you need so
you need to specify the types and that's
most of the work is specifying the types
yeah and there are different ways being
short on this different ways writing the
cdf inside the fivb ceases later on but
there are different ways getting to the
same result and there's also some
sometimes some shortcuts that work for
certain cases though that's typically
how you work and then you write a setup
file that's usually how you do this you
want to automate things you because you
don't mind remember those commands so we
write a setup file and this is very easy
so we just have this this tutorial coins
a setup and then you have size so nice
and for design so nice you just give
this extension a name so that's the way
it's called and then you just list all
the files you ballot mundo compiler can
be more than one and then I give the
option annotate true and we will see in
a moment but it needs the annotation is
a very nice thing to see what actually
happens in the background and then you
call pi since that I've built extension
in place in place means it copies the
result of the shared library directly
into my directory otherwise you have to
go hunt for it somewhere and it deep
inside the [ __ ] directory so there's a
bunch of options you can give here's a
ship's one though easiest put is in a
make file type Mike and there you go you
have this result and then you can import
it see you now import it and here I
import the pure Python function and a
pipe import the type function that's it
that's my testing to our import this
here this is a shout out library
actually so the shaft library is the
name cy underscore 101 dot s 0 in my
case or if your windows PYD is located
in same directories or I can import it
and then I use this thing and I print it
out and you see this result you see if
you use the Pisan function I get an
integer if i use a c function I get the
float because I said I want two doubles
and two doubles will become go to two
pies and float we get a pison float back
obviously that's that's this this dot 0
here is a sign that actually works yeah
so that's pretty simple of course there
might be some more complex use cases you
can also wrap existing I don't show this
you can wrap existing see functions very
nicely you can just import them so to
speak and use them with that it's very
little interface and you can also access
existing structures and a lot of other
things so I have a have the one of those
or what wonders as chemical libraries
such actually doing it so this very nice
it works with spice in 25 26 27 3 it
works with pie
hi because uses see types and then you
can do something similar you can access
all this this this this the structures
in NC the way you want it so let's have
a look and this is the annotation so
that's what you get out of here and size
and generates a lot so lots of sea but
this is not for human consumption
because sighs and still so I think they
still support old versions of move pison
2.4 and then up to 3.3 and then you
generates a lot of lots of sea but
usually most of the sea is not designed
for humans to read because the compiler
which throw most of it out anyway and
you can see here this is pure this is
pure pure python if it's dark yellow
it's pure python pure python and then
you have this this white places and this
white places is pretty much pure pure
cpu core conc codes and then this gives
you some kind of hint what actually
happens so if it's everything's dark L
you probably have to do something if you
wanna get speed improvements and if it's
white you had to see that we already
there won't be much more you can do all
this precise on unless you want to
change your algorithms for sure but in
terms of the compilation step so that's
very nice you get this information out
of out of science and you can see what
you can do that's very interactive thing
you just run it look in your browser and
you see it's updated and you see what
changed oh that's pretty fast and there
are some other nice things now the newer
versions of size and support the
decorator syntax so instead of actually
putting this putting this this
definition of double and everything they
have the inside actually that I don't
even use the W deposit pi symbol sizably
deducted that we be double but I just
putting it in inside the code you can
just put in the decorator so you have
this decorator and then I think if your
imports ice and you don't compile it
just you do it like this then it will
run as a normal just a normal claim to
your Python function nothing special to
do but if you have a size and compiler
new compare
item is a setup file you will end up
with an extension we can use the
extension so you don't have too many
changes to your code it just works so
that's a very nice thing because those
decorators are very good tools for a lot
of things and then decorators are
typically used for cross-cutting
concerns and this is a cross-cutting
unser and has nothing to do with your
functionality of your code in per se but
you want to compile it which is
something more a tooling thing and that
what decorators are grateful and that's
why you can use it here and you can just
specify a lot of things you can do most
of things with decorators they are
special a few special things that are
too deep inside when you just move
pointers around but you can do sighs
live you and do more sophisticated
things but you certainly go then dislike
Reuters might not work but but for a lot
of those cases you can be broke and now
you have a function works with bison so
if somebody doesn't have size installed
it works its normal person but you can
also use the decison that's a nice thing
yet another thing is there's pie epix
import pics import just get a dozen
babies with this explicit setup steps so
you don't have to create a set up but py
file and run it and compile it but you
just write you just write this but this
is my extension 5 there's a py exercise
musical for just gotta read a few
comments here but it's the same thing
and then here you're huge estes a pie
pie pics import pics important store and
now i can import this one and this one
actually landed imported it tries to
compile it even tries to compile pison
files compile ever seeing / forts
importing which works you can import the
extension so it will put the extension
there and you can important books so
that's that's something very nice for
experimenting you don't have to call the
ex this additional setup file so that's
a pretty nice way broken visit okay
let's get a bit deeper let's look at the
buffer on the face we talked about the
bathroom to face another Ian talked
about it already so it's a number at
number vampire inspired standards to
access these data structures from Python
and size and supports this bar under
phase which is important and just look
at this this is just the sea struct that
gives you some kind of hint is this a
pizen
it's distracting but you see they have a
pipe object here and then you have some
information about it the size item size
looks are similar to but Empire I saw
you see and this is this this pipe our
object and this helps to avoid copying
data from c to Paislee back and forth
you just keep it there and you just have
a point or some reference and say okay
it's my data and I know what they mean
what the data means and then you don't
have to copy things back and forth
because copying data can be costly
that's pretty much just the effect you
get when you're using this powerful
interface so you don't need a bundle
with all the details if you don't want
to you just know that can help you make
things faster because you can access it
also as well you can maybe help you
profiling things ok let's look an
example I just chose one example but I
do here and try to two different
approaches I didn't try all of all
approaches you can try many more compare
all the speeds but just see what about
size needs doing so I have a and P is
there to in to Dean umpire race it's the
same shape and I do some calculations
just some a plus B times 2 plus 8 times
B and the science of this array is 2005
2005 about 4 million elements enters
just walk this is to erase and a try a
few different approaches to paralyze
things make things faster and see what
as an example but sighs and actually can
do with it okay the first my first 90
things using multiprocessing even if I
know it might not be very useful because
you have this big array and you want to
do rather simple calculation compared to
the size the first thing you have to
chop this thing into sub arrays because
you want to distribute it over over a
few things so the first thing I'm doing
I I just get this I just make sure both
sides the same shape here that's
something I want and then I just half
its vertical and the horizontal the
middle of this you see I do a floor
division here so i want to have three
integers as a result and it could get
pretty much the middle of this of this
thing and then you slice object slice
objects also same thing than using
Collins but it's maybe need an answer
the rock because you can reuse them so
you sly subjects
just means i have my for my big array
and a drop it in for soccer race that's
pretty much what it means to have fought
sup race and you go over this upper race
and but i'm doing here i use
multiprocessing pool playa synchronous
and it's just ok i throw in my my data
here here for all of them and just a
function i want to call it will you see
in a minute on a call and then if the
output i write an output which isn't
it's just an empty array this is same
shape is the same shape and data type as
a and then i go through the result and
you get so this one is a synchronous so
it's just sent off for a synchronous
calls to success numpy and then we
scatter i'm blocking and get the result
back this is multiprocessing very nice
the problem is the sixth time slowed and
normal person because this is this is a
use case that's not very useful for
number four multiprocessing goes much
processing needs to serialize data so
average the subtle race has to be
sterilized pickled sent to a process
calculated and the result has to compact
the same way and this is kind of
something you shouldn't do with this
type of problem for multiprocessing you
will need something you don't have to
distribute the big amount of data we
just sent something like some sample
simple numbers of parameters something
to process calculate something and keep
most of the calculations they aren't
sent a small result back so the pickling
overhead would be small compared to the
calculation and this is obviously
multiprocessing is not good for this
they just as an example if we just say
we have might personally go power you
will get slower doing part that it might
happen of course you always need to
measure we get an effect out of it okay
that's one one one thing you can do and
now you can also access this buffer in
the face and that gets a bit more
involved so you have to write a bit more
information in here first there's a few
more decorators size and supplies like
you can turn bound checks off and wrap
around so a kind of turn of all the
security net i have i can turn them on
makes things slow and i would get error
messages something is wrong so then you
debug your code you should battle turn
them on Steve something wrong so if you
go outside of your
bounds and stuff like this which can
happen you might not be already used it
in person person person typically eyes
and gives you gives you exceptions if
something like this happens but here you
just would go silent and you would
create maybe a strange results so I turn
them off to make it faster and then here
you see now i'm writing a function in
this function is supposed to work on a
sub array so i don't get a full to full
array i only get one quarter of the way
at the time and i'll do this by using
the buffer interface so I don't copy the
whole array and put them as a copy and
get it back but rather get kind of
pointless to this to the coordinates of
this sub array and that's what I'm doing
this is is a structure here so I have to
have this this object with double and
the dimensions I know this will be a two
dimensional array and then this is
that's a type yeah and there's a buffer
and this is not allowed to be none if
it's none that will be an exception
that's why this mod man means and I do
the suppose of them and never thought
one which is her output so I have two
inputs and an output an output is just
also something output I put in and then
having to you have to do a few checks so
I have to do the CDF so that's I'd tell
ok that's an unsigned integer for x and
y for inner and outer i would like to
use and then i have to make sure the
shapes of both arrays agreed because if
I don't check this there might be some
strange results and if they don't agree
i have to write a typo so i have to be
have to do a few things here to make it
work and if there is no output yeah
because output defaults to none then i
create an empty array which just has the
same shape after perform so i create an
output to put things in and then I just
get a shortcut to this is a buffer won
the Internet out or just to going
through my loop variables this will be
the next slide so I have this one and
now goes through and I just write x ray
for X and X range something usually
don't write in Python you things fast
but this you go here's goes to seishun
you can do this and go through and now
i'm doing this this calculation this is
my calculation a plus B times 2 plus a
times B now this is a and this is B here
called power for one and power for 2 in
this case because I buffer and this is
my calculation I'm doing and this is
something usually you want you want this
to end the void an umpire for
doing something like this button sizes
different because eventually the stuff
will be translated to see you get a
silly loop out of it okay this is a this
is this function that that works on this
tile and this is not doing anything by
itself but will be called by an add
another function and this one now looks
like this that this one gets my erection
a and B in here and return something you
see I have my array 2d views but I
called it here when this one gets to
double erase a and B in our case and
this will be the result me spit out and
we still have to do the definition here
get those things and now I go through
them to the whole thing it is just two
dimension here and have this buffer and
you'll go through and do the same
calculation here on codons in on auto
and then I do this as a whole I'm go
through the whole stuff here and now I
have this thing twice yeah now now of
course go through and I calculate on
this those four four things you see I
get my whole array in here and the
Doozers with those pieces is a 44 times
so I have to do all those checks again
that I make sure that the shapes are all
right otherwise I gotta get a problem
here and then a [ __ ] output again and
then you see I'm doing my vertical and
splitting and I have for supper race now
is I have for supper race and this fold
I call this a few function here and just
for supper race and it's a surprise I've
programmed this all out you can write
make it nice and write a loop probably
but I programmed is allowed to see how
this works so now I have for
calculations and so for supper race and
this is just calling the other functions
just defined before yeah so that's why
there's many function so this one is
just using the auto function as defined
before and calling it and I put in this
quad one and quad to quadriplegic I
create with the slices here so these are
the slices so instead of
think the slices all the time this would
be a lot of would be very noisy just to
find them ones here and reuse in here so
a sly subject is nothing special to
built-in in Python so that's pretty much
the thing and that means now I have for
calculations and the four different
things so it's a bit broke doing it here
manually probably could automate a few
things but as a to show you how this
works now you can run it on this other
thing and actually this is this gives
you a very nice speed up if you just run
it without anything in parallel here
because you have this effect of what's
called tiling so instead of going
through all the rows of your array he
just go through a sub array in this is
shorter and then you can take advantage
of this to sketch effects and the
streets up things quite a while and
haven't done anything in parallel yet
just doing it instead of going for the
whole thing going to parts of those
things this would be one thing to speed
up things so you see it's pretty
low-level actually here so you think
more and see terms done in price and
terms but you have the full if you can
dig a guy to get a lot of leverage if
you wanted to optimize things and try
things out you can to try different
sizes of this array size this is just
operations those kind of things and can
proc with it okay now this is not
parallel yet but this is a you need to
set it up like this to actually in the
end use OpenMP the due to the open MPs
the de facto standard to the Imperial
things and pretty much all the modern
compilers of support openmp and though
you it's very nice you can use this
because sighs and supports OpenMP and
open AP itself is it's a big tool and
has a lot of options and for this one
because it kind of you can run this this
paralyzation under different kind of
miss different options to how they broke
so in this case I can use the static so
every every process gets the same amount
of resources you can also give open and
Peter flex I do it yourself and figure
out which one takes needs more
computational time but since I drop my
array enforced sizes for equal sizes i
can just use a static one so he has a
lot of things you can do with it just as
an example here now i have
import parallel so I have this this set
up what they have before they I can walk
on those four sub arrays and now this is
was a prerequisite to make it parallel
though this domain decomposition
something probably most the time you
have to do some way or the other two to
get it to work in parallel and you see
now I have to have this list these two
till extra arcs I have to supply been a
compiler have to say- open minus F open
NP here for the for the extra compiler
extra link arguments to actually enable
openmp and then I have to import
parallel to make things work in parallel
and then now you see how this works here
i define a CDF function with the same
person it looks very similar but I did
before but to say no good you see that's
something that you can do only this
functions that are pure see so as soon
as you use the no kill option everything
has to pc as soon as we work with the
Pisan object you cannot do this that's a
problem therefore you have to make sure
everything is see if you if you still
have some pies and objects in the other
compiler will complain it doesn't work
so we have to be totally in sealant if
you use some Python no Gil doesn't rock
the rest is a simple thing which are
adjusted here only that the ad is no
kill the rest is what we had before
going going through here and then the
next one I have this view again there's
output and I deuces deuces checking
again of the of the types and if they
are some no output as added to the idea
here I had to find a thread ID I broke
the first night imitation I do here is
with threats so you can broke the
threats if you like to explicitly so you
can address each thread separately if
you like to for our prime it's not
problem is not not very necessary that's
actually a better solution but to show
you what you can do is you can
explicitly work for threats and go to
this level of threats and that's why I
need to assign this thread ID and then
you see how it looks like here i turn on
my no Gil see i make a list with ids
this is important here and then I turn a
no-kill and
say parallel pearl and number of threads
is four so i used for threads here so
you can actually specify the number of
threads there and then i create get my
thread ID and now a Van de Graaff is my
list and since lists don't apply some
objects I cannot use skills we have to
say with skill so I have another context
manager here and turn on the gill but
only for the small forces one line and
then it turns off the guilt or the
killer's off on then every time it's off
again and every time I go through the
loop because it several times here ssl
hmmm here it will be will not get the
thread i do so every stretch will call
this code and then you will can identify
this right ID and then i explicitly
programmed if-else loops for the trouble
probably you could do this more
elegantly but this shows you very nicely
what I'm doing here and actually now
instead of legions of slices I uses bead
and Colin here which is exactly the same
as our second our quadrant slicing here
but only in a different spelling maybe
see a different thing how it works so
this is a first quadrant the second
quadrant and so on and every quadrant
will be calculating a different thread
and since I'm running all under OpenMP
every stretch rate already run on a
different cpu oh when abbottabad but
about the operating office algorithms
over the SS cpu and i have four
different threats and unlike pison
threats which are just in one cpu thread
so to speak on just piled on only one
cpu and python takes care that only can
one run one can run at an end in 10 time
here they can be really run in parallel
and that's the difference but for this
you have to reuse no Gil otherwise this
doesn't work and as soon as you touch
the Pisan object like here you have to
turn on the kill again so that's
something a bit low level probably
compared with out what else we do this
Python but you would have access to this
parallelism here and then I just print
out the ID so see that I have this four
threads running and yeah the
distributor's over this false threats ok
this is pretty tedious so if I have
eight threats you would write 7ls
statements that's probably not real
arrogance so if you do the same thing
anyway you can use part of the range
so if you if you know they have this for
supper a sand but they are all the same
actually it was the same thing I could
use a pre-arranged that the
introductions the same I don't need a
thread ID and then I do something like
this you see now it's much shorter quote
quote I just say no Gil and have this
this this this size pound check is a
decorator and the context manager at the
same time so i can use it as a decorator
and the context manager so I uses as a
context manager here and i have this to
contact stones on and then i can goes
with this parallel p range so the
parallel range and let's throw in my
function i'm going to crawl and here i
can even give it this this is openmp
instructions or static means every
thread gets the same amount of CPU time
so to speak on they have three more
other options that can make things more
dynamic and you can give more rock
desert to OpenMP to make things dynamic
which would be better if you have if not
equal but comes with some overhead
likely because there are some context
switching between them and then the
number of threads here and then just go
through here and I see now go and don't
don't this thing on this par fours here
and control in this just like this was
much nicer to work with I don't have to
bother with threats and you can use P
arrange those not that an elegant as a
doll one the other one the threads would
be very useful if you really have
threats that might have different things
to do then you you could use threats but
since they have the same thing to do you
can use P Ranger distributed and now it
works in parallel it's a little bit
noise around here compared to a paisa
loop but it's much much less it's just
as context manager here and then this
aesthetic thing that you have here and
compare this if you compared with the
multi processing code it's pretty
similar yeah so but that's what you get
out of it and then let's look at the
results so the speed up so if you are
you if I use different numbers of
threads it is just running a machine
this to physical cores and hyper
sweating so it looks like I get a speed
above exactly two if i use for threats
which kind of course balance with my
physical course and the hyper solving
doesn't have any effect more or less on
the thing so that the hyper setting
doesn't
if you had for physical calls that might
be different but you see you get a speed
up using different numbers of threads
which kind of proves that this OpenMP
Brooks you get something comes get
something out of it this comes with a
grain of salt because the the other
implementation I showed before vez just
the tiling without going parallel
remember when I just go in this four
quadrants and work on them separately
gave me the speed up of four without
doing anything without doing anything
special I gotta get a sweet up before
because I get this this tiling effect
which in this case it's better than the
parallel effect so parallelize not
everything that might be a lot of other
things you can explore before you go to
the parallel route to get things but if
I had would have more course it would be
much much likely that it scales pretty
nicely as long as your array is big
enough and things are broke with this
then get some speed up okay this is the
conclusion you see it's the code is
quite a bit involved and you might not
understand all the details here and
there are the SQ sony also talk to other
tools that might be better for other
approaches sighs an open p allow to work
and you can turn of the bigger lead
which works and you can run threads in
provo and do something you cannot do in
pure python that's the first thing but
they are surprised to it because you
need to write more code and you need to
write understand not only passing but
only see and openmp to certain degree
this is a simple example if things get
more complex that will be strange error
messages maybe and they might be caused
by some code in this and the sea level
or the openmp and other things and then
makes things more complex of course and
it was part of the paisa safety net you
have so you do have to check for shapes
of a race and you have to check for a
lot of things which come for free Wiz
Python because here everything is
optimized for seein as you see I even
thrown off the bound check and stuff so
probably when Ed Bucky when the turn
unbound check first to make sure
everything works and exactly excellent
unity to need to notice I'm see if you
if you need to if you want to work with
sizing and you need to know a few of
see because that's actually how the big
advantage comes from you know see then
you can dive deep in see so if you know
co anyway already then sizin is likely a
good tool because you can apply all the
knowledge of C is very new to you that
might be quite a bit of learning curve
protos a few things are different there
ok this is my conclusions maybe gives
you one example that is kind of useful
and you can retry and play visit those
things and usually that's that's that's
something of course there can be more
complex things and then there might be
some problems that I don't mention here
but hope you get some impression but you
can do this item thank you very much I
think we have time for questions yeah
yeah the slides will be online so I put
the slides online here and I also put a
puts a source code also you can try the
thing should run so I compile those
things so you can try and play visit
that's where the defect come from yeah
no no I haven't done any under our
benchmarking so this is something you
could do other benchmarking and opencl
if you have my mud for this type of
problem might work but you have to
really have to measure but it's likely
that those things they have an effect
because it's embarrassing parallel to go
to speak because everything every
operation is independent so you should
you should good scale up to more
processors new CPUs any more questions
yeah yeah see see important it's if you
want to importer it says extension files
in Python so you have you have to this
the problem is very precise and you have
pure python code you have pure C code
and you have sizing code which can do
both and not everything fits together
everything mrs. C it's it's C and
everything is normal font name is Python
and from pump if you cannot call
directly to those see files we have to
have intermediate layer of as Python in
between also time there some new things
now about that's typically how it works
you have to have some that's why I had
this wrapper around you have to see that
for you cannot wait call this one and
the other imports that you can also
write extensions where I can
what existing see libraries and and and
compile them this vizio code so riding a
sandy i haven't covered writing
extensions here so you can write the
extension c++ extensions which is with
the different topic but it's pretty easy
compared to doing it by hand doing
behind you right so much and you get it
two lines yeah the this this is a
surcoat you now we have to distinguish
because you have a compiled step between
but the developers doing and what the
users doing so as I said you can use it
you use this setup py generate an
extension then you give users extension
he never you never even sees a compiler
and a sequel he just sees an extension
which is just a shared library yeah any
more questions then I want to go quickly
back to but I started from so of course
I have some new people so if you just to
repeat so that will be your Python in in
july this year in berlin which is just
maybe now from here a friend a bit more
maybe and it would be is very
interesting because you get a full week
of the european pison community speaking
training so trainings are in parallel
there we have posters and then the PI
data Berlin will be there right included
into Europe I sins of the 24th to the
27th you will have pi ditto the Linder
also so if you like the PI theta event
you invited to come there and then just
extend a little bit and come to Europe
eyes and also that's something I would
like advertise here and this is the
pricing event in Europe and you should
not necessarily they have in close to
300 submissions for talks and trainings
and posters so that will be a lot and
something for everybody I guess thank
you very much